[Music]
How's it going everyone? How y'all
doing? Um yeah, let's go. Let's go.
Let's get the vibes going. Let's get the
vibes going. Um yeah, excited to to chat
uh here today. I I I you know by the end
of this what I hope that you get out of
it is uh maybe some some advice I wish I
had had uh before kind of trying to hold
on to the tail of the dragon um with the
past uh months of of what we've been up
to and uh you know so I think for us you
know I how many people here have heard
of uh bolt new by the way just kind of
curious oh wow dang I guess I'm I'm
still used to being like has anyone
heard of stack blitz and there'd be like
two hands and that sort of thing. Um,
okay. So, cool. So, everyone's used this
thing, you're aware of it, tried it out.
Um, so, uh, is anyone aware of how long
we were around as a company before we
launched Bolt.
Seven years. Yeah. Um, so to to kind of
hit the graph of this thing. So, if you
if you rewind, uh, you know, the X-axis,
uh, way back seven years, the the ARR
starting at the bottom of this, that's
in November, uh, sorry, that's October
of last year is when that thing starts.
The ARR was 0.7 million. That's that's
over seven years what it had gotten up
to, right? And at the time that we
launched Bolt, uh you know, we were a
team of less than 20 people. And when we
put it online, we had absolutely no idea
what was going to happen. Like we
thought, uh we were getting ready to
shut down the company actually at the
end of last year. Um this was like the
last, you know, uh not like pivot of the
company because it's the same core
technology that was used to build this
product that we've been building for
seven years. But we we couldn't figure
out a way to kind of create a commercial
offering that made sense at a venture
scale. We've been around for a long time
and uh so you know our expectations were
like if we can add $100,000 of ARR by
the end of the year with this thing that
would be that would be gamechanging,
right? Obviously uh kind of beyond our
wildest expectations of what happened
and since then we've over doubled it.
Um, but the I think that to me the the
really crazy thing about the graph
you're looking at is how clean of of a
ramp that is, right? Like there's not
this like jagged edges during the the
insanity of the early days. And the
product we put online was really it's
it's like those race cars like it was an
MVP. It's like those race cars where
they strip everything out and it's just
like metal. There's no back seat.
There's no side seat. It's just like
this, you know, that's kind of what the
product was like. So the fact that, you
know, our team was able to scale this,
uh, was just unbelievably impressive.
And so that's I kind of want to talk
about what that looked like and how to
structure teams to be able to actually
rally together and, um, you know, be
able to to scale what would normally
take at least a year to grow into,
right? uh the best analogy of what it
feels like if you ever seen the movie
300 um during this time right like that
on this revenue ramp kind of like
probably at the tail end of that we were
looking at probably 30 or 40,000 active
customers at that point you know on
month two a team of less than 20 people
so this kind of apt you got this small
group of people you know surrounded by
just tens of thousands of of things that
are uh maybe not trying to kill you in
our sense but like but it it felt like
that I mean the support load was was
unbelievable we had no there was not a
person on our team that had you know
success officer support uh in their
title, right? It was my chief of staff
and I largely responded to support
tickets, whatnot, but the the main thing
we were able to make this work because
it was this just incredible uh
camaraderie amongst the people on our
team and we've been working together for
seven years at that point. Um and we
were just extremely aligned and very
lean and very fast and those were not
new things for us like that's how we had
been operating all along, right? And one
of the core uh you know philosophies
that we set out like my co-founder and I
uh he's actually a childhood friend of
mine. He and I have been building uh
websites together since for like 20
years now literally since we were like
13 years old. And uh the company we did
before Stackless before this one we had
actually bootstrapped that thing from
the ground up ourselves. Like we we were
broke living on couches. Um and and when
you do that you really learn how far a
dollar can stretch. And it's very
obvious how most startups are just
incredibly inefficient when you're in
the in the phase of trying to find
product market fit, right? And uh so
this is kind of where this mantra that
that we've had at our company for, you
know, uh almost a decade now really
kicked in, which is you really want a
small number of people with more context
per head because what that means is that
people at the company have more agency.
They can just go and build things. They
don't have to get permission to build
things, right? um there's not this whole
chain of command you have to go through
etc. Everyone's very empowered. Things
just move a lot faster. You can just go
and and you know make uh uh you know
immediate impact which again is really
important when you're dealing with this
sort of like scale, right? Um of course
for startups the name of the game when
you're finding product market fit is you
need to be able to take as many shots on
goal as you possibly can because like
fundamentally getting product market fit
is is just like an enterprise sales
pipeline. Like if if you're a sales an
enterprise sales rep and you want to
close a million dollars a pipeline, you
don't go and talk to like three people
and assume you're going to close a
million dollars of pipeline. You're
talking to like 100 200 people at your
top of funnel. Of those, you know, half
of those maybe take the next call. Of
those, you know, maybe 10 are remaining
that are actually warm leads. Of those,
you close three or something, right?
Same thing with like, you know, building
products and and building startups in
the early phases. You need to stick
around as long as you possibly can,
which means you need a lower burn rate.
You do not want to have more people at
the company, right? Um because humans
are the most expensive thing for a
company. Doesn't mean you shouldn't hire
them, but it means that you know it's
important for your ability to have a
durable uh you know enough time to
actually take shots on goal. Case in
point, one of our main competitors of
our previous product when we were in the
IDE space, they got acquired basically
stripped for parts two weeks before we
launched bowl, right? Right? And we were
on that same trajectory, but purely a
matter of they they didn't have enough
runway to actually get to the other side
of this thing. And and they were good.
Like they would have been meaningful
competitors in this space to us, right?
Um anyway, so that's this is you know
there's a whole bunch of reasons this is
important. Those are kind of the main
reasons. Um again, this is not new. A
lot of uh you know, folks that do
startups repeat this sort of thing. You
want to have people that have a great
shared uh you know shared set of core
values that uh you know where it's low
ego, high trust. Um they're obsessed
with making the user uh successful and
underneath you know chaos, they have
grit and resilience, right?
If if you if you aren't in this sort of
insane situation like we were uh and you
have folks that are already having
trouble with the ups and downs of of a
startup, I will tell you it it would not
have been possible to do what we did um
with folks that that didn't have just
incredible grit and ability to just
check their ego and focus on what really
mattered, right? Um so great people is
what it's always about. Um, so that's I
think from a team perspective, those are
the things that that really uh stick out
to me from, you know, what what allowed
us to uh uh you really scale with the
traction that we saw um and we're seeing
to handle and this this probably applies
to um not just like this crazy extreme
situation that that we are in growing
the company, but in general, you know,
at startups, there's going to be things
times when just everything's on fire,
right? And uh and and a lot of you
probably relate to this where it's like
sometimes it's good things are on fire.
It's just, you know, tons of customers.
Sometimes it's bad things that are on
fire, right? Um and there's just lots of
them. And the question is how do you how
do you prioritize? And the best analogy
that that uh I have uh leaned into like
as an operator is like imagine that
you're, you know, a fire truck squad.
You have one truck and you're in a town
that's completely on fire. Where do you
start? And the answer is you have to
make hard decisions and choose where the
high impact uh areas are from
infrastructure uh you know and and the
key people that that need to be saved,
right? And it's tough because all these
things it's it's it's hard to gauge uh
sometimes what's actually going to be
the most important thing. But that's the
job, right, of of firefighting. And so
that's uh and a lot of and that and what
you're what you're saying is there are
some fires that are just going to have
to burn and that's okay, right? Um but
if we focus on on saving the right
things, focus on the right things, um
that'll make up for, you know, all the
other things that we that we have to let
go because we simply can't focus on
everything as a small team. But there's
actually an added benefit of that is
that you don't get lost in the million
things. If you if you just hired a whole
bunch of people, you feel like you have
to do all of these things. It turns out
focusing on 10% of the things often gets
you the lion share of of the result that
actually matters. So, it forces you to
actually have clearer thinking and what
you're going to go put your time and
focus into as a team, right? Um, and uh,
you know, I kind of mentioned the story
of for us, you know, we we've been
around for a long time, like eight years
now as a company. And, you know, over
the past eight years in the valley,
there's been a lot of things that people
will say and believe and you go to
things you gatherings of people and
they'll kind of repeat these same
things, then they'll change all of a
sudden. So, a couple of these like just
random examples. Uh, back when we
started 2017, 2018, remote work was like
very, uh, looked down upon. It was like
there's no way you could do that. Um, my
co-founder and I, we just, you know, the
best candidates we saw were coming in
from all around the world. And so, we
uh, and we had actually gotten an office
in SF. We thought we were going to set
up shop here. Uh, 6 months into paying
this, you know, $5,000 a month office.
We like, what are we doing? Like, we
haven't hired a single person here. Uh,
we went fully in on remote in like 2018.
pandemic hits, then the world's like
remote work, this is it. Like how, you
know, blah blah blah. And now we're kind
of flipping back to previous. You need
to have your own thinking, right?
Because if if you just try and follow
whatever, you know, the press or
investors, whatever, say, it's it's
going to be a nightmare. You're you're
going to be distracted by a whole bunch
of decisions that fundamentally are not
actually coming from your assessment of
of reality. Um, another great one is to
the topic of tiny teams. If you were
raising money in 20, if you were a
company in 2021, you had investors, they
were screaming at you, ours were, uh,
you should raise more money. You should
hire a whole bunch more people. That's
how this is successful. And then if you
waited 12 months in 2022, they would
come back and they'd say, you need to
lay off a whole bunch of people. You
need to stop spending money. And and you
know, and for us, we were like, we never
were spending money. We never did
increase the headcount. Right? So you
you know, it's you want to have these
sort of bets that you make. And I I
don't want to say it's you don't want to
be contrarian for contrarian sake. some
of this stuff uh that that is repeated
actually, you know, tends to be durable
advice. But I would just encourage you
to like think for yourself and don't
just adopt a lot of the hive mind stuff
because the, you know, it seems like the
best companies tend to have independent
decision-m that really allows them to
succeed. So, um, of course, uh, leading
from the front is very important. Again,
this is not a new thing, but what I'll
say um in the first week of Bul being
online, it was uh it was it was pretty
touchandgo because again, the product
was very was very brittle. Um and it
became clear to me like if if if I don't
myself and the team don't get out and
make ourselves visible to the community
and and engage with them, people are
going to churn and they're going to go
away and they're not they're going to
lose belief pretty quickly because we we
have so much work to do. And so we
started running a a weekly office hour
session where we let all users tune in
on uh YouTube and X or whatever and we
just showed them we were building. We're
like, "Hey, we hear you. Here's the
things we're working on. Here's when we
think they're going to land." People
would ask questions, etc. And so, you
know, again, how do you smooth that sort
of, you know, uh growth curve? You you
go and do things that don't scale
because user love is hard to quantify on
on, you know, specifically, but oh my
god, it works. And that's that's how you
can really scale um you know love for a
product like this. Um
last thing uh I'll mention you know as
far as like tools that we used um
support is is something that is now like
you can there's a lot of AI tools that
are coming out right that help you scale
uh you know all aspects of your
business. Support has been a huge one
for us. The first two months that we
were online I I mentioned earlier uh my
chief of staff and I were the primary
support people uh spending a lot of our
time doing emails. We ended up um
picking up a tool called Parah Help. If
anyone's heard of those guys, but they
are our the AI assistant called SAM from
those guys is the top rated uh support
assistant um for us and takes out 90% of
our tickets automatically, right? A year
ago, two years ago, we would have had to
hire 50 people to to go and scale to
that, right?
um the leverage that that you can have
by integrating AI and there's even
custom things we're doing in our product
you know training our own you know
little uh uh models to help people be
successful within the product experience
that would have required human support
before there's a lot of things you can
do um by not just making AI product but
also building around the entire customer
success journey to be um you know
powered by that
that name
parel yeah yeah parel so I think they're
we're one of their customers I think
cursor is using them um couple of just
brilliant uh you know young young guys I
think out of Europe or something running
that company. Um, and I I mentioned this
before with like kind of leading from
the front, but community. This is
something that AI cannot replace. Going
and and actually talking to users, like
creating a space for users to try out
your product and like learn from each
other, um, is so key. And this has
always kind of been the case, right? But
especially now uh if you're building an
AI product, it's really important that
folks can like learn from each other and
learn in a place where they can get help
u you know from pros right and from the
community themselves because this is
another way you can really scale the
customer experience without having to
add headcount within your company itself
right and so one of the kind of cool
ways that we're doing this I don't know
if anyone's seen um we are throwing the
world's largest hackathon right now
actually for this entire month if you go
to hackathon.dev dev. You can check it
out. We have passed the Guinness World
Record, by the way. This is like
already. So, let's go. We've got 80
something thousand people that are
participating. Um, but basically, we've
got this amazing event going on. We have
dozens of people coming to help uh
provide support and uh you as folks are
building out their projects, trying out
the product. Um, and this has been just
the most the craziest ROI we've ever
seen from a a marketing initiative we've
ever done. both due to the scale but
also the thoughtfulness and like getting
augmenting it with both the AI support
and the community support etc. um this
sort of stuff really works, right? So,
um to kind of wrap up here, uh these
are, you know, the main takeaways. if
you wanted to like take a photo of, you
know, the TLDDR or whatever. Um, these
are kind of the main things that, you
know, just stuck out to me from the the
past couple of months of, uh, of our
experience that really made a difference
and and, you know, again, like I said,
it was very touchandgo, right, for the
first especially the first two months
just how unexpected and unprepared we
were, you know, for for what happened.
Uh, without this these things, like this
would not have worked and it wouldn't be
working now, right? Uh, and to boil that
down, it's like, you know, you don't
want to hire an army. You want a small
number of Spartans, right? That's kind
of the mentality that we look for when
we hire people onto the team. So, um,
all right, with that, uh, let's go. Uh,
so this is where you can find me. Um, I
have to like go to SFO like immediately
after this, but if if if anyone wants to
chat about stuff or has questions,
that's where I am on X and then that's
my my email address there. Um, I think
we have one minute for questions
actually if anyone has a burning one.
There's a microphone up here if you want
to come on up. But yeah. Yeah.
Hey, how did you decide what to build?
Like did you have a framework for you
know talking to users or did you just
ideulate and you know ship product
experiments and see see what stuck or
Yeah. What what was the process there?
Yeah. you're talking about like for like
kind of like how we decided to build
bolt or and and even after
we we tried out like uh probably five
different things last year and all of
them I mean I think it's you know all
the things I've ever built that that
really seem to stick with users and
resonate always started with something
that I myself thought was cool you know
uh which sounds like very obvious but
there's al I've most of the things I've
built in my career have been things that
sounded good and like it's like hey this
should like maybe increase our AR are,
but it like did intrinsically wasn't
something that I was like
so so so stoked about that I couldn't
sleep at night. Bolt was one of those
things, you know, and and then we
certainly put in front of users. Uh
people seemed excited. Um and I'll tell
you this, what what the user feedback we
got from the early Bolt sessions before
we launched versus some like launching
stacks was the exact same and the
outcomes couldn't have been more
different. Right? So again, it's all
about just like taking shots on goal
because you you just don't know until
you actually get it out into the world.
Um, you can certainly get the early
feedback, but um, you know, it's it's
all about just getting to launch,
getting it out there, and, you know,
iterating as fast as you can. So,
am I cut? Okay. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I
can't take anymore. Thank you. Thank you
for having me. Um, hopefully this is
helpful.
[Music]